E aí
[Música]
Olá eu sou futurista há 20 anos
e depois de uma vida intensa em grandes
empresas como executiva eu resolvi sair
daquele escritório de organograma que
era um mundo muito pequeno para mim
chegou a ser o mundo muito pequeno e
resolvi alcançar Via Láctea e eu fui
estudar turismo nos Estados Unidos do
lado da NASA
e a onde tinha aquela Estação Space
Johnson que lançou Apollo 11 com os três
astronautas que pisaram na lua
e essa foi uma experiência
o que me fez
a frutificar sonhos de Infância porque
quando eu era criança
e eu ficava olhando para o céu
o olhar das estrelas e ficar pensando
como eu queria conhecer esse mundo de
conhecido como eu queria explorar esse
universo
E aí
e para mim o futuro era totalmente
aberto
Ah e não tinha limite
é porque o universo era o limite e assim
que acontece com as crianças nós não
temos limite na imaginação e nos desejos
aí eu fui para escola
hoje eu fui para escola e aí começaram a
me dizer que eu tinha escolher uma
profissão aquela profissão na lista a
profissão da moda ou a profissão que
pagava mais eu chegava em casa
e também na família olha essa profissão
vai ser boa vai te dar futuro
o que tem escolas e bem eu aprendi umas
matérias
o que era tudo certeza não tinha
incerteza alguma todo era previsível
tudo era continua provado
em ciências matemática que eu centro de
ER
a história que me ensinava o passado e
me fazia olhar o futuro como se fosse
uma linha reta como projeção dando do
passado e tem mais gente eu acho que
muitos de vocês aqui
e não passava na prova porque eu esqueci
as datas que situação
bom então vão falando lá em casa com as
pessoas ao redor rosa para você ter um
futuro na vida só depende de você
e se você ralar se você que tem ar você
vai chegar aonde você quer Puxa vida não
me contaram que tinha coisas
imprevisíveis que tinha atalhos
o que tinha mudanças de Rota e eu cresci
dessa cultura me mostrando que tudo era
facilmente previsível que tudo era
controlado Sabe aquele pensamento
científico do ano passado né que a gente
chama de cartesiano e eu vivi quase a
vida toda nessa nesse tipo de cultura
com esse pensamento aí aos 40 anos eu
descobrir que não era nada disso aos 40
anos
e quando eu fui estudar o futurismo eu
descobri que o futuro não era linha reta
que o futuro era imprevisível
Ah e não tinha nem spoiler da época
e eu aprendi
é mais do que tudo
o que o futuro não era destino eu
aprendi que o futuro era plural uma
multiplicidade de caminhos
a e foi aí que eu também me fez sentir
começou a me fazer sentido seguir
adiante seguir me lancei nessa profissão
que eu estou 20 anos
eu comecei a dar aula comecei a
trabalhar com empresas formando
executivos e nós estamos hoje no momento
o mais importante da história da
humanidade não sou eu quem fala apenas
são os historiadores são futuristas são
sociólogos
a todos nós aqui estamos vivendo numa
época que não é na época de mudança é
uma mudança de época histórica
a e é muito bom eu sei que dá fio da
barriga é muito confuso é muito inseguro
às vezes falta o ar mais é nesse momento
que a gente vai mudar e aí eu fico
pensando
E qual é o futuro que está diante para
os mais jovens
Oi como vai ser o futuro para quem tem
mais futuro que a gente e é isso que eu
tô fazendo aqui hoje gente eu tô aqui
para falar da importância de ensinar um
futuro assim como todo mundo aprende a
história
eu aprendi o passado nós também temos
que aprender o futuro
e essa é a minha atual causa eu já tive
várias Causas em toda minha vida causa
de gênero de mídia do midiativismo né da
cultura de paz atualmente Essa é a minha
grande causa e olha só
oi gente hoje tem na escola como um
canal de Formação desse futuro que está
aí com essa as crianças com esses jovens
que estão aí só que essas escolas estão
o ensinando formando pessoas para
profissões que não vão existir daqui a
pouquinho daqui a 5 10 anos muitas
profissões vou acabar e os métodos que
se usam não funcionam mais nós estamos
uma revolução digital e as escolas ainda
estão bem atrás ó
Ah e por quê para explorar um mundo
o que a gente não tem a mínima ideia do
que vai ser então não não temos que
rever toda essa escola todo esse sistema
de educação porque agora a gente é agora
o momento da Grande Virada que nós temos
que mudar essa história nós temos que
pensar naquele que tem mais futuro que
nós o futuro é mais deles do que o nosso
E aí eu também como eu sei a pensar
profundamente profundamente
e depois que a gente fica mais velho a
gente começa a ter esses pensamentos e
eu comecei a me e conectar com esse
sentido de ancestralidade
E aí
o que que tu meus netos fico três netos
a Sofia de cinco anos o tom de quatro e
o Bento de 2
e eu comecei a me conectar com o futuro
de uma forma diferente depois de 20 anos
como futurista eu comecei a olhar para o
futuro com maior senso de
responsabilidade o que que eu vou deixar
para eles e o que que eu vou deixar para
todas as crianças desse mundo porque
assim como eu herdei o mundo dos meus
antecessores eles e todas as crianças
vão e dar um mundo que eu estou deixando
e eu comecei a perguntar também
o que qualidade eu tenho como acestral
eu tô sendo uma boa ancestral que
realmente eu tô fazendo eles e para
todas as crianças desse mundo e nós
todos aqui somos ancestrais tem sensor
pensem só nas crianças que estão na vida
de vocês das crianças que vocês conhecem
que não conhecem Todos nós somos astrais
e que qualidade que nós temos nessa
ancestralidade
e é preciso pensar no futuro e trabalhar
no futuro para quem tem mais futuro as
nossas crianças e o que nós estamos
fazendo como vocês traz nós estamos
ocupando o futuro que é deles a gente
fala muito de colonização de terra
colonização de país mas existe a
colonização do Futuro
o agente age como se não tivesse amanhã
e a gente pensa no curto prazo o tempo
todo é o filósofo tem um filósofo inglês
chamado Romano pen drive que ele fala
que a sociedade atual vive de um
curto-prazista patológico como se a
gente não tivesse a responsabilidade de
deixar um Rastro saudável sustentável
pros que vem e olha só o País de Gales o
ano passado criou o ministério para as
futuras gerações virou lei aquilo que
era um ato institucional a cinco anos
atrás hoje virou uma lei que faz com que
qualquer ação do governo esteja atrelada
a esse compromisso com as com as futuras
gerações é maravilhoso Japão o Japão
para planejar algumas cidades do Japão
chama crianças se chama jovens e
adolescentes para eles visualizarem o
futuro que ele quer
se querem viver nessa cidade do futuro
e aqui nós não estamos fazendo nada
disso e aqui eu vim para falar sobre a
importância de ensinar o futuro e aí
vocês vão pensar para ir ensinar o
futuro como assim futuro ninguém vê
futuro não dá para prever o futuro não
existe certo futuro não existe
É mas o passado existe
o passado não existe
e o passado é registrado por aqui é
fatos pros itens históricos por museus
muita gente só isso aprendi o passado
então É urgente E muito se fala do
futuro da educação é o que mais se fala
hoje futuro da educação né e assim
conseguir um pouco de retórica é uma
coisa meio que bonita falar o futuro da
Educação
é mas ninguém fala do Futuro na educação
e é isso que tem que faz todo sentido
nesse momento para mim como futurista e
para muitas outras pessoas que trabalham
com Futuro no mundo é um movimento
recente Educar para o futuro ensinar o
futuro é tão importante quanto ensinar a
história
e porquê
e é hoje o agora nós temos que começar
agora abrir seus horizontes para que
esses jovens consigam ver luz para o que
tá que eles consigam botar a mão no
futuro que eles querem e que não seja
aquilo que a não olha você tem que
seguir essa profissão isso Acabou ele
tem que ele tem que criar uma profissão
que não existe essa é a profissão por
mais louca que seja por mais estranha
que seja essa é a profissão que vai ser
a previsão do futuro é a profissão do
sonho é a profissão criada por ele e é
por isso que as escolas têm que integrar
o futurismo e o que que é o futurismo
e o futurismo é uma ciência dentro dos
estudos do Futuro que também se chama de
for site de prospectiva quem estuda as
mudanças as que estão mais perto as que
estão mais longe para que a gente possa
criar o futuro desejado Esse é o
futurismo e eu tô envolvida
é uma forma tão visceral com essa coisa
chamada que eu recebi como ancestral né
aí ensinar o futuro não só para
executivos não só para adultos mas
também paga as crianças que tem mais
futuro que todos Nossa eu quero fazer
uma pergunta agora quem aqui estudou
futuro na escola
a ninguém
e ela te esperar
o e tenho certeza que vocês também
estiveram nós falamos para vocês que
tudo era muito simples tudo era era só
chegar lá né era tudo muito previsível
mas não é assim nós estamos vivendo um
momento
e em que se a gente não olhar para o
futuro e se acostumar com esse alto
nível de incerteza que vai ser cada vez
maior e principalmente a ajudar os
jovens a lidar com a certeza vai ser
terrível então o futurismo ele ajuda e
prepara os jovens para esse futuro e o
poder das imagens Como estão as imagens
o Homem top que foi um futurista
Lendário do século 20 e ele falava assim
o futuro começa com uma imagem uma
imagem mental o que que é isso na imagem
mental ela é meio que uma semente
o que fertilizou pensamento e que faz
você
a criar em novas ideias e descobrir
coisas que ninguém descobriu e eu
pergunto qual é a qualidade de imagens
que hoje estão sendo no trilhas nas
escolas São imagens que igual fazem as
pessoas Florescer em que trazem
esperança que estimulam que dão coragem
que deu esperança ou são imagens que dão
medo
o que trazem descrença
o que trazem Tranquilidade e que
paralisam
E hoje você ser você pergunta para os
jovens em geral pede para olhar para o
futuro eles não vem futuro porque eles
não conseguem o sentimento é de quem não
tem futuro Então pessoal vamos colocar
descolonizar esse futuro e vamos dar as
mãos para eles então é essa minha
mensagem né E como ensinar o futuro
e existem dezenas de ferramentas de
experiências e Messias é o que eu faço
há muitos anos como vários outros
futuristas fazem nós temos o movimento
que eu represento no Brasil e na América
Latina que se chama kit de filtro ensino
futuro estamos já em 30 países e essa é
a minha atual paixão Depois que eu fui
avó eu encontrei o meu lugar o meu novo
lugar gente faz todo sentido para mim
como futurista das mãos para as crianças
porque eles precisam A gente eu quero
que eles valem Luz Para o Futuro as
plantas precisam de luz para crescer as
pessoas também
a notícia foi um presidente na minha
vida porque o meu professor Peter Bishop
que é um dos maiores futuristas do mundo
e convidou a 2 anos atrás a integrar o
movimento mundial foi um presente da
vida para mim o Peter ele já formou mais
de 200 futurista profissionais como eu e
ele se aposentou E aí ele perguntou pera
aí ele ele também pensou e disse eu 40
anos em Sidney o futuro para adultos
agora eu vou ensinar o futuro para quem
tem mais futuro aqui é o Peter ensinando
crianças aqui sou eu ensinando o
futurismo para professores né E nós
temos uma ferramenta que é a cartilha
pensar futuros aqui alguns adolescentes
que a gente chamou em um evento no meio
de futuristas adultos falando sobre o
que eles pensam do Futuro planta
inteligência quanto
e nessa gerações que não têm voz não tem
espaço nas decisões públicas não tem
espaço na família das escolas nós
estamos colonizando o futuro dele nós
temos que dar mais espaço e o poder do
Imaginário recriar as imagens que regam
a vida deles eu quero agora dizer uma
coisa muito importante para vocês pense
no ano 2000 e sem todas as crianças que
estão chegando agora filhos netos
vizinhos sobrinhos todas essas crianças
é bem certamente vão viver 2100 talvez
passar disso Qual é o futuro que a gente
vai penso tá preparando para essas
próximas décadas que eles vão viver
e eu quero agora que vocês já nos olhos
e pensa em uma criança da sua vida e
vejo essa criança em 2100 feche os olhos
como ela está Ela tá vendo na foto sua
peguei ela olha para foto e disse essa
pessoa me ajudou a criar esse cultura e
e os indígenas norte-americanos já
diziam
e nós não estamos a a terra dos nossos
antecessores Nossa ganhamos essa terra
emprestada das Crianças então eu quero
aqui nós todos como ancestrais nos vemos
a mão uns com os outros nos unindo nessa
responsabilidade de ancestrais que nós
somos e dar as mãos para essas crianças
três jovens que precisam que precisam da
nossa ajuda estejam comigo e se juntem
esse movimento e muito obrigada pela
atenção
E aí